pas une goutte de pluie depuis plus d'un
mois et demi sur la hausse et vouvray
des étés secs le domaine alias sont
inconnus daniel à 84 ans l'année 76 est
un souvenir marquant mais c'est l'été 59
qui ressemble le plus à celui de 2022 la
sécheresse commençant au début du mois
mars et va durer jusqu'aux vendanges
pratiquement pas très très peu de
précipitations par contre la différence
c'est qu'on n'a pas cessé pointes de
chaleur que l'on a cette année on a
jusqu à 30 32 go est bon mais parle 35
40 comme en voit maintenant les sols
argilo-calcaires de là aussi vous vrai
ont une grande qualité durant cette
sécheresse large il retient l'eau
résultat aujourd'hui les fruits se sont
bien développées le bémol se trouve dans
les jeunes vignes ses 257 ont été
fraîchement plantés
normalement il peut de temps en temps là
on a le problème de la rosa est
normalement n'a jamais ou très rarement
dans l indique l'adp il n'a pas plu du
tout de plus que ces plantes et à ce qui
veut dire ça fait trois fois déjà que
mon fils ait été obligé d'arroser cette
notation si on veut que quelqu'un de
bien
daniel reste confiant la récolte 2022
devrait devenir un beau millésime
notamment pour les vins moelleux